[Music]
row after row scattered all over this
airfield is destroyed helicopters
there's even holes in the fuselage
in the bodies the ones that are intact
if you come inside them
and you enter the cockpit
there's nothing here but shattered glass
and destroyed equipment
[Music]
like this helicopter we also we
completed that outlands but
some
lens may be missing to that just not
started we will try to maybe in two days
we will
solve
[Music]
when the islamic emirates of afghanistan
entered kabul the first guarantee they
gave was general amnesty i'm sure they
will stand by their words if we all left
who would have brought back this
airfield to life
it doesn't matter to me who runs the
country our duty is to protect the
borders protect the assets and the
resources of afghanistan
the maintenance gets harder the more
complicated it becomes so the real
question is
not so much can the taliban get these
things off the ground one time or even a
small number of times the question is
for how long could they sustain
those airframes without being able to do
some of the higher level maintenance
that they require
you